don't go
[Music]
in front of the bed and sheet
made fun of Muhammad without thinking
twice never thought that I'd have to
fight your ridiculum
but if you insist then just just heed my
advice so
[Music]
I hope it will be held responsible
cause he's preparing his case
yeah legally responsible
half asian boo right in your face for
the life of me I cannot decipher what
made you think that this was wise and
will never compromise for the life of me
I cannot believe you try to bet us for
this
I made my half asian
[Music]
friend if you think that your legal team
is better just know there's at least one
thing you can bet that with my half
asian lawyer takes the court room floor
think about it now I'll be the voice
inside your head
it will be held responsible
[Applause]
as he's preparing his King
yeah legally responsible
[Music]
all the way
I cannot decipher what made you think
that this was wise and will never come
for the life of me
I cannot
go through Friday
[Music]
he don't care if you're straight okay
[Applause]
will be held responsible
he's preparing his King
[Music]
I cannot
do what made you think that this was
[Music]
I cannot believe you try to find a
better Sports since now I made my half
Asia
[Music]
please
we're going to give you some predictions
here tonight kind of go through what we
think are the need to knows and by that
I mean none of it is really necessary I
guess not third chair it's like a joint
chair like he's like it's like a Siamese
twin growing out of my shoulder Nick de
Paulo we're growing my club
[Music]
sanctimonious is my primary care
position
and there he is Mr Ed's teeth hey Nikki
Haley looks good tonight
but it is true that cable news is dying
it is dying and this is one of we talked
about that up there this is one of the
first events where you're seeing them
die and Rumble and places like that are
going to take them out put the nail in
the coffin boys
by the way none of that checks out two
million early votes were cast we are
gearing up for 2024 which I believe is
the most important election of our
lifetime
[Music]
[Applause]
yesterday
[Music]
foreign
that's a slurp that is a slurp I don't
know if we're supposed to because people
say they want me to keep it I don't know
if you don't want me to disturb anymore
but uh glad to be back uh with you here
I was I was doing third chair a little
bit last week because I had some other
things to tend to and then tomorrow at 8
30 Eastern we're going to live stream
the debate yes
the GOP debate number two now I expect
this to be I would expect a debate to be
somewhat boring so our stream will not
yes
just to be clear if you have to watch it
you can watch it along with us uh but we
have a lot to get to before that of
course we have a this weekend Biden
today
um I don't know if you know this but you
are paying uh we see a looming
government shutdown and that could
happen that yeah which affects your life
not a whole lot you know if you want to
go to like a national park you know
Yellowstone your chances of being
attacked by a bear go up slightly
seven percent especially if you're
getting a picnic basket or you put an
apple pie on the windowsill now we may
face a shutdown but at the same time
you're paying for Ukrainian salaries uh
you know 130 something billion dollars
now pledged another story that's pretty
interesting on behalf of uh of of
Indians Native Americans they're suing
this group Civil Rights group is suing
the Washington commanders formerly the
Redskins because they're not offended
but it turns out that white were
again so this is a perfect example of
affected white people are offended on
behalf white liberals I should say are
offended on behalf of minorities and
they're like oh yeah well hold on we're
not with them and then the Dallas mayor
who was a Democrat has now become a
republican that's a party switch want to
know what you think about that and when
someone makes a switch in power you can
comment below are you skeptical that
there are wolf in sheep's clothing or do
you think that people just change their
minds and they evolve right there are
two schools of thought on that I'm
always cautiously optimistic number two
Gerald CEO how are you sir I'm doing
well I'm cautiously optimistic as well I
just don't know I don't know I don't
know they're gonna just get rid of this
guy riveting analysis I know I don't
know
I do know how about this he's a
republican he's been a republican the
entire time it was a deep fake to get
elected really there you go you also
just show that you don't know what deep
fake means when you hear this in third
chair he brings a smile to all of our
faces when he when he's here turns up
the vibe sort of Thursday October 19th
he'll be at Summit City comedy club in
Fort Wayne Indiana gross
thank you for your service Josh
underscore Firestone how are you sir
good good Fort Wayne's not gross yeah it
is
I've been there before and it just
reminds me of a permanent Fairgrounds
yes I think after the rides have left
yeah exactly it's just trash and trash
cans just a city of carnies yeah come
see me guys we'll play knock over the
clowns yes exactly October you know they
used to have actual 22 rifles you know
at those fairs yeah kids they would do
Target with 22. yeah yeah some of them
still do I was at uh the fair this
weekend in Washington Washington State
Fair night got to shoot a crossbow for a
chance for a giant tiger I didn't win it
you didn't win the tiger no no no are
you sure but you showed a crossbow I
shot a crossbow it's almost real too wow
good for you yeah it was cool I played a
game this weekend where they have like
these these throwing axes but they're
safe so they're plastic that you can get
at Costco what and I'm fantastic and I'm
like wow this is an entirely useless
skill
if only I did this with darts or pool I
can what am I going to tell people I'm
really good at The Fake Plastic ax throw
you shouldn't tell people that
but it's a fun game I'm glad I didn't do
the real ones those things can bounce
back and by the way I don't know this
Show's going to go off the rails I have
a a hunch today so uh if at any point
you're watching on YouTube first off hit
the like button but if you see this
while you're watching on YouTube
head on over and watch it at Rumble who
by the way are under attack from the
official UK government right now and
they've been short sold boy hey they go
after the they go after the top creators
at Rumble right whether you like you go
after Andrew take go after ourselves
right the hit pieces and then you have
Russell Brand and then I go after the
CEO of Rumble themselves it's almost
like it's coordinated it really seems
like that by the way a lot of
institutional money going into Rumble
right now so that should tell you
something somebody may be just driving
the price down so they can buy it on the
cheap you mean going into Short Selling
Rumble no I mean actually going into
buying the stock oh buying into this
Rumble right now so interesting plays
going on here it's not just uh the
market no this is not free enterprise no
so all right let's go uh before anything
else let's go uh to this uh this is do
we have the lukewarm yeah this is a uh
it's a tick tocker on a feminist podcast
oh geez I just threw up in my mouth a
little bit why what's that phrase tick
tocker feminist podcast
that's my favorite kind of tick tocker
yeah I was here they are making the
claim that uh we need to stop fearing
fatness in uh the lukewarm take of the
week
[Music]
so many of us just absolute dread and
fear the possibility of looking fast
like what about this like what if too
late it was okay to have her gut like
come out a little bit no I love that
it's like that's like cotton order like
pretty hot it's like what if what if we
didn't fear fatness the way we do oh
please stop stop this this stupid
everything
[Music]
ah you know what a BMI of 42 is just
physically unattractive to me you're fat
phobic how do you know the phobia as a
contact therapy like with me with a
spider
her muffin top it's the most ridiculous
no no what you should fear is your heart
giving up on you
can I just say your gut sticking out a
little bit was a long time ago yes I
don't know if you're advocating for
other people I'm not trying to be mean
I'm just saying you're not describing
the situation accurately and that's not
fair yes your gut requires a crossing
guard to redirect traffic
[Laughter]
if you can't get over it by by seeing it
you know like if you see a monster in
the movies right and you're like oh this
is terrifying and then you finally see
for example leprechaun
the Pogo you're like let's not scare
anymore then okay it's a fear it's an
irrational fear you can get over it if
you're you don't like something and you
see it and it still grosses you out I
mean it's not a fear it means it's
rational it means like oh hold on a
second that's that's not even
subcutaneous but that's visceral that's
surrounding your organs your body's
trying to tell you something namely that
you're dying
I was at the fair this weekend too I
promise you zero fat chicks are afraid
of showing their belly
they're proud of it dude it's just
everything is a fear it's a way of
shutting down doubt oh it's it's fear oh
I'm saying black lives matter I I don't
like the fact that you know billions of
dollars oh it's just hate everything
they disagree with is hate or fear and
they have a bunch of Yes Men Women nose
rings either I love that do you do you
love it do you actually love it do you
love it and by the way find me one one
male sex symbol who's fat now don't say
Chris Farley don't say they had to be
immensely talented there are no fat
Pride male models because we know that
women aren't going to think we're
beautiful and just here's the ultimate
Point here young ladies don't don't
listen to these amoebas okay you're not
going to live a happier life you're
going to live a shorter life you'll die
young and you'll live a lonely life in
an unhealthy life riddled with health
problems it's not a phobia your doctor
is not afraid of you getting fat
yeah
he's concerned yeah I hate he's got too
many fat customers sorry patience what
do you think a doctor does with someone
like this who walks I'm like all right
uh sex well I'm non-binary figures yeah
well look it seems like maybe you could
cut back on that are you afraid of my
fat you know what just whatever do
whatever you want and you know what it
seems like it's working well go for it
eat 20 and call me in the morning or
don't I don't care I don't care
and broke just to be clear who's they I
mean people in charge who want a
completely Placid society which brings
us to at this point uh of course the man
he's been at every mass shooting every
uh you know he's been calling black men
boy and now his Outreach for black
voters has reached another level this
brings us to this weekend Biden if you
have a problem
the two of the great art
icle Legacy of hip-hop in America
llj Cool J uh
[Applause]
uh by the way that boy's got he got
man's got biceps bigger than my thighs I
think he's
an MC light both of you thank you
because they're both at the light off on
the mic you know you're uh you're all
here to listen to the New Edition Mike
Bivens 40 years producing music that
lifts our souls after every mass
shooting we hear a simple message the
same message all over the country and
I've been to every mass shooting wait if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black
he's been to every mass shooting
have you been to every initiation for
the Van Buren boys
I'm not buying it but by the way who the
hell is MC light is that a real I mean
that's a real person he mixed up MC
Hammer and Gordon Lightfoot well he said
llj Cool J you know and she was like the
first female rapper to have like a solo
album go MC light something yeah yeah
but I didn't know who she was I had to
look her up yeah I know exactly but I
don't think that's who he was talking
about yeah no no I don't think so either
I don't think he has a clue
has bigger biceps in my thighs that's
not hard to do your thighs are the size
of ETS
I've been in every mass shooting by the
way again the vast majority of mass
shootings are gang violence gang on gang
violence just like when they try to say
oh it's the number one killer of
children no no If you eliminate actually
15 to 19 year olds again who are in
gangs largely people in inner city areas
the number one killer of children I mean
above guns uh toasters
by the way for I thought I thought his
quote of calling a grown black man boy
was going to be from the 80s yeah and
it's not it was from that I was like did
you just said that boy and I'm like okay
you just can't get the racism out of Joe
Biden come on come on down here boy
we're gonna vote for me boy what
come on boy boy can I get it up
what
it's just so bad what should Joe Biden's
uh rapper name be I can comment below I
think MC shits his pants
[Laughter]
I don't bedazzled Biden I don't know MC
drops a deuce yeah
[Laughter]
all right let's go on now to uh a little
snooze yeah sorry that's good it's a
little snoozex
[Laughter]
instead of stuff instead of selling
sneakers of blood in them you just you
just constantly walks around the blood
bag transfusion like Mad Max he has a
blood person on his car it's just a guy
with his with the IV and I'm just
and one of the here you know you wonder
where's the where's the left remember it
was a comedic Witch Hunt when George
Bush was president and then when Donald
Trump was President no one out there
really I mean I know you have people who
are kind of on the right you have that
sort of La podcast scene from Joe Rogan
but like the bill Burrs of the world is
there nothing oh there's someone not
enough material here he said he was
there in every mass shooting right like
someone has to take him aside and just
tell them that like maybe you're not
saying what it is that you think you're
saying I was gonna shut the up dude
that was great bye
episode on Comedy that they've missed I
know do impressions of the people for
them remember every single time George
Bush spoke it was every comedian it was
like it was like a hack off I feel like
there's even more to make fun of now
yeah of course than there was back then
and they just don't really touch on it
like man I guess he's not the best
president but he's better than the other
guy no he's not no he's not hit the like
button if you don't think that this man
is better than the other guy any other
guy by the way the other guy we're
talking about is a guy who created the
best economy that we have experienced in
our lifetimes period Bar None not even
close even though you don't like his
tweets
all right X's posts it's true social
well that that now that now he's
actually gotten better on truth it's
pretty funny hey it's pretty he's got
good stuff yeah he is he's funny too he
does memes and stuff yeah speaking of
memes okay so now the uh you know some
people are going to want me to call them
like Native Americans no I'm not going
to but we need to talk about this this
is another example of uh what white
people actually co-opt in culture to
what white do is what white people do is
when we talk about cultural
appropriation what we really experience
from the left is offense appropriation
like they decide to take offense for
someone who isn't actually offended
that's why we do the segment of black
and white on the gray issue you just
didn't know you were mad yet yeah that's
all it is that's basically what they
think it's just appropriation for what
you should be like taco Tuesday is
offensive and then the Mexican
immigrants who are selling Tacos on
Tuesday in a sombrero are like uh
have you been to a Chinese restaurant
have you have you seen the decor they
don't care so this goes to Native
Americans
white liberals they stole this piece of
Native American culture and now the
Native Americans are fighting to get it
back Indians Redskins as they so don't
mind being called as we now know so the
Native American Guardians Association
you may have heard of this story last
week but there's an update here they
actually filed a defamation lawsuit
yesterday against the Washington
commanders for quote delegitimizing the
group and its efforts to restore the
team's name back to Redskins so just to
be clear the name was Redskins
then white people said it was offensive
they demanded it be changed it never
actually came from the Native Americans
themselves and now they're saying that's
actually offensive because you're
removing something that we actually
thought kinda made us look cool here's a
clip now what do you want from this
lawsuit exactly well we want monetary
damages for the comments that the
Commander's employee made regarding Naga
call them a fake group to a season box a
ticket box holder what do things stand
with your position on the name change
and reversing the name back to the to
the Redskins well I think it should be
changed back to the Redskins you know
the logo on the Redskins helmet is an
actual person is Chief white calf and so
every time they go out on that field
White Castle the Redskins battling on
the football field with the same honor
and integrity and courage and they they
should continue to honor that and just
to be clear like just so you know let me
skip ahead a little bit this is
something they would do with Native
Americans right Redskins came from
Native Americans they would associate
some notable body part or some notable
action then they would often add a color
it's like white calf why have you seen
his calves
you could look like they're cut from
diamonds
he's got Mike menser calves we'll call
them white calves
he never goes tending no yes
blue single dad what he drinks a lot he
gets blue
I'll call him red nose pops how about
that so the history of the Redskins name
to give it it was in 1769 there was a
prominent tribal leader Chief mosquito
again these are the names they would use
mosquito he referred to Native Americans
as Redskins there you go and tribal
members they've even been participating
in the Washington Redskins uh their
celebrations honoring Native Americans
for a very very long time 90 of Native
Americans are not offended by the name
Redskins ninety percent you can't find
ninety percent of people to agree on
anything you can find 90 of people in
the Democratic party to agree on sex
changes for minors though you're pretty
close
so what he was referring to is um the
the Naga lawyer that's the acronym here
not to be confused is referring to a
text message from a Commander's
representatives to a Luxury Box season
ticket holder and it said you understand
that the people the Naga the North
American group that started this
petition is a fake group well that's
that's at 133 000 signatures that's a
mighty large fake group oh wow meanwhile
antifa is just an idea it's not an
organization at all no no no no I
definitely understand that they haven't
had a problem with the idea of this is
white people largely white women who
don't give a rat's ass about football
and by the way while we're determining
what should be I'm surprised they
haven't taken issue with the
Washington's basketball team the
Washington Grand Wizards that seems like
it would be a layup when you actually
think
yeah I don't I don't think that was yeah
they're on fire
yeah we're burning cross good for you
thank you thank you I don't let that
Jersey touch the ground
hit the like button whether you're on
rumble or YouTube it helps with the if
you want to see the team change its name
back to Redskins and look this is just
one other example in a long line of
examples of the left being offended on
behalf of other people here's a silver
lining just don't play along with it
yeah don't go
African-American latinx no no none of it
just continue with your life and guess
what no one actually gets offended
except for white with nose rings
who think that you're afraid of fat
I think you're afraid of it so that's
why they show it to you yes exactly look
at it
you're afraid of heights cut up on top
of the Sears Tower you're afraid of fat
here's lizzo playing Thomas Jefferson's
flute with her ass so
whoever's flipping Madison flute
admonish me Madison's flute I think it
was Madison's food if I'm not mistaken
all right do you have the admonish
button Tim admonish me it was Madison's
flute and she didn't play it with her
ass
that doesn't leave many options my
daughter
oh no the president so here's another
example right the left being offended on
BF so latinx only three percent of
Hispanics use that term and by the way I
think that's very generous only three
percent of Hispanics even understand the
term yeah
just to be clear you just pissed me off
when he was writing the story he goes
latinx and I'm like
most Hispanic people I know are very
proud
they don't like being called uh they're
like being called the wrong one yeah
Mexican or Puerto Rican or I mean look
at gay William oh he's cute
Puerto Rican can't stand it no also do
it they come from you know Latin the
romance languages they're gendered so
these guys don't they don't have a
problem with it like male female they
don't have another category let alone 57
remember back in the day we used to joke
about how Facebook had 57 possible
genders yes now it's well into the
hundreds geez and the answer from the
left to all that is yes that's it that's
their only answers yes okay how about 97
good enough for me
laughs it's just like the BMR oh did you
hear the new genders dropped oh wow who
cares that's like an iOS update yeah
gonna get one every year yeah and you
hate your father so
Asian cultural appropriation was another
one I think it was
name that movie line comment below I
know it the mainstream freaked out when
there was a supermodel um her name was
Carly cross not to be confused
cloths Carly Kloss wore that kimono on a
photo shoot okay so of course white
people outraged the Japanese when I I
know you're going to say Jeff white but
you know they prefer the term yellow
they weren't offended at all when they
saw foreigners wearing a kimono here's
proof
pissed
in opposite room of husband
it's a messed up culture Japanese
culture just because to me I get it it's
my sort of Western lens but you know I
do think that uh it's silly in a lot of
ways it's also very racist if you look
at their tenant loss but guess what they
don't care they don't care about you
wearing a kimono at least they've moved
past that yeah well a lot of these
things are silly and we make fun of them
but it actually distracts from like
actually getting work done in this space
right you're like oh we're offended by
statues so we have to take them down
even though we think George Washington's
probably a pretty swell fella we'll
probably want to keep that one up for
history purposes at the very least but
then we change I think the mascot of the
Indians change from Chief Wahoo to
something else recently the Cleveland
Indians Guardians I would focus it did
it really yeah Guardians is oh that's
the dumbest name
you should focus on playing baseball
well first as a team same thing with the
Washington football they're losing the
culture but this is a perfect example
people say oh cancel culture it's
accountability culture do you have an
idea how much money that costs the
football team to change the stadium to
change the jerseys to change the ads
that go out there it's the same thing
with you have any idea how much it costs
for them to have to change a photo
spread for them to have to change I
don't know go back and retroactively
change books or if you look at Facebook
you look at YouTube you have to change
your content in the guidelines and just
for us we have to go back and change and
re-upload videos because there are new
rules so yeah sure they're losing the
culture War the left is losing the
culture this is why when people say
culture War uh silliness no no without
culture you cease to have a society
that's why they want to destroy culture
it's why they want to destroy the family
they are losing but it's a Shakedown it
costs you a bunch of money now this is
something that's veiled right because
people go along with it they're being
complicit because they're being
pressured by some shareholders or by
some people on a board and then
sometimes it's blatant like people
shaking down Rumble right now which is
by the way huge way to support Rumble
join mug Club mug Club is Rumble Rumble
is mug Club live earthquetter.com mug
club for 89 annually you get this
wonderful hand-edged mug you get our
show you get a full full other hour of
show if you continue on muck we'll be at
Alex Jones on Fridays you get our Friday
show get the Hodge twins you get Brian
Callan you get Mr guns in here we're
going to be adding more and more and all
of Nick de Paulo sorry every day 5 p.m
and it's all under one umbrella that is
still part of Rumble so sometimes it's a
blatant Shakedown and then sometimes
it's a Shakedown with peer pressure it's
like sometimes you know you get a
cigarette shoved in your mouth and
you're told to smoke whole pack like my
dad did
which is when I started liking
cigarettes
mission accomplished and then sometimes
it's the peer pressure of if you're one
of us you'll take a smoke or me and Mr
you know in Michigan it's like if you
want of us and they give you cools ah ew
of course in Austin It's All American
Spirits because it's organic tobacco so
they're losing but the problem is they
only lose once the truth comes out
that's the reason for the show is that
the truth can come out beforehand before
you make a mistake like changing an
entire team to Redskins sorry from
Redskins
nobody cared we had to I think we got
suspended one time on YouTube because I
said Redskins
they don't mind the term nobody cares
just be good at football which you
haven't been for a long time that's all
anybody cares about but the people in
power care that's the problem the people
who can leverage these companies care
the American people don't care and the
Redskins themselves don't care they're
too busy drinking Windex
I don't know where's that girl that wore
kimono is a prom dress like a couple
years back and tons of outrage on
Twitter like dude it's just a prom dress
we used to have this in 2015 that's why
we started cultural appropriation month
every June because we're going no one
actually cares and the only people who
cares are Media Matters or someone like
that they launch some hit piece I have
an idea fine you want to take your
culture back you take every single bit
of it back give us democracy free speech
and uh all of the western values that
have been fantastic that have shaped the
world and made your life better back yes
hey I want I want my culture back the
United States so how about this we're
the greatest country in the world we
never lose a war low taxes First
Amendment Second Amendment and men are
stronger than women physically and women
are better at rearing children there's
the culture that I like here in this
country black white yellow or
paint now let's go on to a shitty
culture what color paints
White to paint their calves yeah exactly
Oh no just one guy can do that just one
guy oh is that white calf no that's
that's Tope brachialis yes he does
Hammer curled he beat out Chief my ship
is to supinate but he has big forearms
as a bodybuilding red skin I don't know
it's a place to add now
I added Mass to my calves how how it was
a Cherokee volume draining yeah they
also they had a vegetarian as well
they're like What's this guy did you go
with Iroquois high intensity it sounds
like Native American my pillow guy
you're gonna love my calf
all right we make the best drums so
So speaking of crappy uh cultures and by
crappy I mean inferior
Ukraine I think it's a crappy one I
don't like it uh if
that's very corrupt is it okay my
opinion has never changed since the
beginning of this it's one crappy
country Russia fighting another crappy
country Ukraine to act as though any of
them are
exist in any world where they provide
anything else to the world aside for
maybe some crops is silly they're
corrupt they can't be trusted they
should just break let's break off the
pool cue let them have tryouts I don't
care anymore so if your government shuts
down next week right which you're told
is the end of the world and it never is
however
a B test this right what rules for the
don't apply to me and in this case me is
Ukraine you don't need to worry about
um Ukraine your government will be shut
down but they'll still be getting all of
the money that they want and ask for
funded by you
the Department of Defense says h u crane
will continue even if there's a
government shutdown the decision was
announced thirdly priorities
met president Texas right now this means
training of Ukrainian Fighters 16
fighter jets will not be interrupted
Ukraine is also scheduled to receive U.S
Abrams Tanks thank God can't we just
send Stacey Abrams and be done with it
she's a tank I don't know I don't know
if they're fat phobic over there in
Ukraine they could be oh no don't want
to do that well that's the purpose you
scare them and you win yeah so I guess
it's an intimidation Factor
The Good News by the way is zelinski
though he's he he's been earning the
extra billions of dollars from us he's
really been putting in that over time
[Music]
the Ukrainian sense of humor is
different a little bit that was supposed
to be funny it was his wiener oh yeah
so here's the thing during government
shutdowns all military activities are
supposed to stop unless it's a threat to
you know National Security like in 2018
the Pentagon kept fighting Isis ah which
that's understandable I get it you know
Isis bad people death to the Western
World entirely I mean I don't know how
much of a threat they are to us at that
point but the Pentagon kept fighting
them okay fine and the defense secretary
by the way has the authority to make
that decision uh and uh this is one of
those situations where I guess a threat
to our national security is Ukraine this
is this is the they want to set just to
be clear that if we don't help Ukraine
and if we don't fund them to the tune of
130 something billion dollars our
national security is at risk because
Russia Russia Russia and of course you
have people who are upset the average
American taxpayer uh are a lot of people
are protesting even ghosts are coming
out of the woodwork well
I'm at the war machine running big guy
covers off the plot force on the crack
in the hose make your head get dumb
so here's the thing we had that and then
unfortunately the Man passed and we were
like well two weeks is enough time to
yeah
it wasn't mocking Smash Mouth we were
like man I'll maybe make people sad
there's other guys in the band yeah we
have so many things in the hopper that
we just will never use yeah
so this comes now just to be clear in
tandem with a 60 and by the way we'll
also I don't know if you know this Black
Rock black rocks involved involved they
get a lot of the money that's always a
lot of fun so this comes in tandem with
a 60 Minutes report showing that
American taxpayers um are not just
paying again this isn't just military
for Ukraine so in other words in the
United States there's a government
shutdown our military has the right to
continue fighting for National Security
however as it applies to Ukraine it
doesn't even necessarily need to be
funding military activity just salaries
of people in Ukraine American taxpayers
are financing more than just weapons we
discovered the US government's buying
seeds and fertilizer for Ukrainian
farmers
and covering the salaries of Ukraine's
First Responders all 57 000 of them oh
great that includes trained this rescue
dog named joy to comb through the
wreckage of Russian strikes looking for
survivors oh that dog is a patriot yeah
yep U.S also funds the divers who we saw
clearing unexploded ammunition from the
country's river that doesn't look like
much of a river to me by the way just to
be clear in total the United States has
pledged 135 billion dollars jeez in Aid
to Ukraine 135 billion dollars while you
may be looking at a shutdown here's how
one Ukrainian Lieutenant justifies all
of said dollar dollar bills some
Americans say we're very sympathetic to
you ukrainians but we're going through
tough times at home and we just can't
afford to keep on supporting you
ukrainians
pays their lives
and we pay for your lives yeah I believe
and I hope that their life scores much
more than money
much more than
taxpayers mind come on do art do art
lives
are our lives worth more this is what
they do right they do the same thing
with gun control if it saves one life
but what if it takes hundreds of
thousands of lives each year because of
defensive uses of firearms right I would
hope Ukraine lives are worth money what
about American lives there are plenty of
Americans who are starving there are
plenty of Americans who don't have homes
there are plenty of Americans who are uh
being kidnapped and being put
permanently into sex trafficking of
course as we know with the uh the
cartels and what's happening with the
open border this is one of those talking
points where it's it shuts it down right
just like fat phobic well we pay without
our lives oh I guess I better not say
anything because he invoked death
now to give you an idea the United
States we have sent six times more than
any European country with 135 billion so
Germany is the next club with 23 billion
a lot less than 135 billion as far as
what's totally pledged England 15.2
billion France 1.8 billion who really
just doesn't get to be a country anymore
as far as I'm concerned and this makes
you understand the context when you look
at the NATO contributions we're all
supposed to pay in at least two percent
right of our GDP the United States 3.5
percent England 1.5 Germany is the next
one 2.2 percent France 2.01 percent
so this is the problem with the UN this
is the problem with NATO this is the
problem with this war when people say
it's our we have to go and defend
Ukraine what they really mean is more
money from the United States exactly and
you never get to stop paying taxes but
your government might shut down and then
they can throw shade at the United
States and say that we're imperialists
and they hate all of our policies they
hate what we're doing we're racists
right by the way can you make sure that
you keep funding this war please so that
we don't get taken over we're the only
reason you still exist right European
Union I'm sorry all of those countries
in Europe right now there's a reason
that NATO was formed there's a reason
you guys were scared crapless because
you had 100 years of war from one
particular part of that you know country
right next to you Russia coming after
you yeah maybe a little bit of gratitude
is in order at this point maybe carrying
your own weight is a little bit in order
at this point you think I should be
grateful I think you should be down on
your niece they should but not
for that I'm doing this for nothing you
little so question for you where do you
think the money is really going comment
that below and hit like if you're sick
of Europe free riding off of America I
don't like Europe
that's why we left
now according to a new CBS news report
American officials are now investigating
four criminal cases involving
non-military Aid in 170 Ukrainian
government officials including
high-ranking Military Officers have been
charged in corruption cases so far this
year for crimes like embezzlement and
accepting bribes you'd think that might
have something to do with Hunter Biden
but of course who knows at this point
170 government officials yeah wow I
thought it read four at the beginning
and there's like wait you buried the
lead it's 170 official government
officials now imagine where those
imagine where those branches go out
imagine where those capillaries how many
businesses do you think those
governments are involved with and who's
set to benefit from all of this just to
be clear BlackRock they're setting up a
bank to finance Ukraine's reconstruction
McKinsey J.P Morgan are also involved in
the project that means consulting which
means yeah toss a few billion words
goodness of their hearts this is pro
bono right JP Chase right yes it's Provo
so BlackRock the same people buying up
single-family homes here in the United
States who lives with Warren Mrs
socialist herself said the these are two
big black
raxes but they'll receive a bailout if
they ever go under if there's a housing
market crash for example that they've
created and they're the ones who stand
to gain from the Perpetual War Machine
it's not that Americans are against a
fight Americans love patent American
Americans love MacArthur for reason
Americans love George Washington said
there has to be a fight that is
righteous this is not a righteous fight
because there are no righteous people
involved and it is not our job fighting
the British obviously that's something
that made sense we wanted to have a
country tea in the harbor was kind of a
big deal if you look at World War II
okay you understand at that point Pearl
Harbor that was the Catalyst for us
getting involved we believe in a fight
there's no reason for us to be involved
in this fight and let's also go through
the math here 135 billion that we've
pledged to Ukraine what could we do with
it we could build six border walls we
could fix Flint's water system 215 times
over we could give every single homeless
vet two million dollars in cash and by
the way I'm not saying that we do these
things I'm just giving you some context
you could do we could provide a I mean I
know he didn't visit for a couple of
weeks but we can provide an actual 50
million dollar check to every family
only in Maui 2700 households would be
eligible so that's right there just what
you could do with this 135 billion
dollars I think this is a good time to
jump in Sam
how long how long have you been sitting
there we're in the middle of a show come
on Sam what's the deal come on well as
you know the IRS has been hiring new
agents at an alarming rate yeah okay Sam
what does this have to do with what does
this have to do with anything while
you're in the studio as your HR
representative it's my duty to look out
for um you all if any of your viewers
owe back taxes or have unfiled returns
tax Network USA can help you out even if
you haven't filed for 10 years exam look
I noticed that you're having a you're
good with like state capitals but you're
not the most you're not the most
literate of the tribe is this an ad are
you reading an ad yes it is oh my gosh
why are you doing an ad I'm the one
who's supposed to do ads here on the
show well because I I get commissioned
are you getting you're getting a
commission okay but that's not the
important thing that is the important
thing for you the important thing is as
I was saying the IRS is well on their
way to hiring their target 87 000 new
agents yeah we know get all the help you
can get
um they've already saved their clients a
billion dollars in back taxes and tax
Network USA also offers bookkeeping
Stephen that's great yes it is it is
great Sam thank you are you done are you
done
okay so what I was saying go to
taxnetworkusa.com Crowder okay Sam we
get it all right Sam we get it be sure
to use the slash Crowder so I can get my
commission tool man can you please bring
up the overlay okay all right that's
enough Sam get out get out
that's not supposed to go to sin he
doesn't make a good point though Joe can
we check him out after the show yeah I
already got a note I haven't paid taxes
in years really you shouldn't admit that
on air
allegedly I don't want to fund I don't
want to fund your friend
all right this seems like it's right up
uh Gerald's wheelhouse uh right here
what is it why why is it up my
wheelhouse what is the URL just so
people just it's tax
taxnetworkusa.com they're pretty good at
saving people money though I will say
they they called us and they're like hey
here's this thing that you missed we're
like oh wow
that's a dinner out whoopsies that's uh
several dinners for all of the Ukrainian
First Responders out yes so uh
Democratic mayor Democratic mayor in
Dallas and Dallas flipped parties he did
his name is Eric Johnson and uh he
switched officially right yes just got
reelected I think at the end of last
year and just to be clear again my
question to you is what do you
immediately did your eyebrows go up and
go ah hold on a second I don't trust
this guy
no anytime somebody flips from being a
Democrat to a republican I'm like yeah
were you really like I need to look at
your policies and wonder why you were a
Democrat that's a big bridge to cross
like yeah I don't know how people do
that well so we'll we'll see if this guy
but he did switch his affiliation it's
caused quite a stir because Dallas Big
Blue City yeah big red States all right
we have a clip
Dallas mayor Eric Johnson says he is
switching parties making the city of
Dallas the largest in the country run by
a republican Fox Sports Bar Canton live
tonight with more on what the change
that's even making the switch Mayor
Johnson said he understands the decision
will surprise many but it is not a shock
to many who closely follow politics I
don't wear a tie because I think my suit
suffice is I don't know
we actually have a clip by the way of
the press conference that he uh that he
actually held oh I'm not gay no more I
am delivered well see that makes me like
it more absolutely very fervent yeah
fantastic
even hit the drum on that
so the Texas democratic party didn't
take the news well they said
given his long-standing Affinity with
Republican leaders in ideology like when
he cozied up with long time podcast host
Ted Cruz at his inauguration this year I
don't know I don't think that podcast
host is his primary kind of credit maybe
Senator Moonlighting as a senator yeah
yeah they say this announcement is
neither surprising nor unwelcome in
other words
you can't fire me I quit yeah we didn't
want you anyway we want you anyway
that's why we supported you in your last
race good riddance
well you're still mayor and now you're
Republican son of a we didn't
think this through
switch Yeah you can just switch
apparently so you're like use their
money to get Alexa
office collect all of the Soros money
there you go and then just switch
oh wow well I think it's gonna be hard
to convince him that you're on their
team now I'll just what I'll do is I'll
go and I'll say I was living a lie I'm
actually a woman oh and that'll be when
they say well there's all this evidence
that you're not I'll say that was all a
cry for help right that was clearly a
cry for help I was repressed I'm
actually a woman and I would like to run
for uh Senate as a woman and I would
like some money and sir also said
and I'll say okay thank you and then
I'll become I mean they can't argue with
you take all this money
I mean I don't I think you're in a good
position for this but comment below if
you guys ever want me to run for the
only way I would ever run for office is
if it was a total Kamikaze gotta be a
gag or they bring up every like hey did
you in fact say this I go I don't know
sounds like me
yes
great so he wrote In The Wall Street
Journal law he explained why he switched
parties and he made uh some claims about
cities yeah now he wants to run Dallas
differently so we'll actually go through
this now we'll make all the references
publicly available with our sort of
claims in his article and uh the truth
so here's a claim that he made he said
that uh Democrat leaders have failed to
keep Cities Safe and one of the quotes
is he said Mayors and other local
elected officials have failed to make
Public Safety a priority how dare he and
this this is good because he's actually
writing in his op-ed all of the reasons
right reasons that can be fact checked
so I think that's a step in the right
direction I agree and the truth
that's actually right that is correct
yes it is correct yeah violent crime you
see it switch but no no in this case
he's just right violent crime has been
ravaging uh the big cities of America
now Chicago Police say there were 75
shootings across the Father's Day and
Juneteenth weekend 13 people were killed
the violence happened on almost every
side of town including the Bucktown
neighborhood this is just normal we see
this stuff all the time I become so
accustomed to it my own tenderloin
just this weekend John caught a shooting
on one of the many security cameras he
has set up outside his home in it you
can see a man shooting a gun multiple
times in the middle of an intersection
as people and cars go by football
there's people living in their cars
trash all over the place needles
everywhere alarming numbers from the
Seattle Police Department 2022 the
highest rate of crime on City record in
15 years well do you feel safe and say
Channel no and why is that there's just
too much going on on the streets naked
bike rides yeah exactly
tandem bikes no seats that's the
solution everyone knows the solution to
City crime is tandem bikes with no seats
so to give you an idea look this if
leftist policies worked in big cities
they would be Utopia I started doing
sort of super videos on location videos
back in 2010 where I did Detroit and
ruins and I covered A to Z everything
that happened in Detroit was the
wealthiest city in the country in the
1950s and it didn't accidentally become
a crap hole that was because of far left
government intervention and by the way a
ton of money pumping into it so violent
crime in cities from 21 to 2022. New
York City was up 22 percent Chicago was
up 41 percent Austin in 2021 experienced
the highest murder rate in decades of
course the liberal mayor there who by
the way called the mayor of San
Francisco to determine how to deal with
his homeless problem he was on The Joe
Rogan show to talk about that no no no
no he how do I make it worse yeah
exactly
please tell me it's like the Commander's
calling the Guardians for advice yeah I
don't understand the sports reference
all right
I assume they're bad right well they're
both Indian thing week oh okay now I
remember
so in Austin though here's the thing so
highest murder rate and you'll say yeah
but then it went down sure in 2023 after
state troopers were brought in so that
means I haven't had to be involved and
he's a wheelchair guy now violent crime
in Dallas is actually down which kind of
surprised me
yeah
so do you think that American cities can
be saved you know you can comment below
I don't know that the the idea of major
cities uh really functions today as they
used to I mean I think you you'll
probably have more mid-sized cities I
don't know it seems like a lot of people
out there even if you want to be in this
you don't want to really be in New York
or Chicago or La anymore it seems like
cities you have cities like Grand Rapids
Austin at one point in time yeah um but
you know there are places in Iowa I
guess that people are saying yeah it's
like a mid-sized city that has what you
need but it's not suffocating I'm
thinking that that's going to be sort of
if nothing else the blueprint for urban
planning going forward if they do it
just these giant mega cities uh even
left us don't see me there it's a
blueprint for survival too like I I
would never feel safe in the middle of
it and I'm a big I very rarely in my
life feel unsafe right right in most
situations but walking downtown is with
kids with what no way there's no chance
that I would feel safe well you're a
giant so by yourself
so that's what I'm saying I just yeah I
wouldn't feel safe in these places
um here's another claim that this uh
this mayor who just wished parties uh
makes and all the references are
available lotuscretory.com he said that
the the left has failed at developing
their cities he said most of these local
leaders are proud Democrats who view
cities as Laboratories for liberalism
rather than as Havens for opportunity
and free enterprise now that's something
that could seem to be subjective but
here's the truth when you look at the
results
right again yeah he's right again uh if
you look at leftist policies and what
they've done to quote-unquote Urban
centers uh it's ruined them arkellos and
his mother own this 10-unit Lincoln Park
apartment complex last year's tax bill
all 10 units combined was 23 674 but now
look at this the same 10 units are now
128 282 dollars this year up 440 percent
so gravy closure is just the latest in a
string of San Francisco retailers that
are closing on Market Street including
the Westfield centers Banana Republic in
Nordstrom as well as Nordstrom Rack and
anthropology across the street from the
Westfield Center the entire block is
empty storefronts it's not related to
Cove it's because we have a criminal
environment that's tolerated and allowed
to flourish here yeah and by the way
when people talk about the American
dream being dead and they talk about
housing prices going up they're largely
talking about big cities areas run by
leftists who by the way these are the
places that are supposed to have quote
unquote affordable housing you know
where you can actually still get
relatively affordable housing move out
towards the country
yeah drive to the suburbs then keep
driving the American dream is still
alive and well especially if you can
work from home for a couple of days or
you're willing to make a 45-minute
commute so these places that help the
poor that help the downtrodden hey hold
on a second let's think about the Left
Right eco-friendly right they're
supposed to help the poor they're
supposed to eliminate biases right
racism Prejudice okay yeah yeah so when
you think of big cities cities like
Chicago or cities like Austin or cities
like San Francisco do you think of clean
eco-friendly affordable cities where
everyone gets along across racial
boundaries and ideologies nope
you have to drive 100 miles out to a
church to find that yeah you know what
actually helps in these situations I
don't know uh jobs good jobs they're
gonna say Godzilla no
he tore up San Francisco is that final
call now I understand why he's coming so
you know it's just more like a reset
that he does yeah like let me burn this
thing down we'll start again and by the
way pro-business policies they've LED
over to over 200 companies relocating to
in and around Dallas that's even idea
yeah just from just from California
Toyota State Farm Liberty Mutual yeah
huge huge they want to live in America
yes exactly they want to live in America
Texas want to live in America and then
they come here and they about well
you know I like Texas but it's not as
Progressive
your progressivism destroyed your job go
back there I don't really want to go
back to Torrance then shut up and
consume your freedom and vote
conservative
eat your freedom
now eat your freedom or you don't get
your second amendment I'll take two
bowls of Freedom please you know me yeah
I'm going to force feed you Freedom
until you get gout now
a claim that this man makes uh uh the
mayor of Dallas who switched parties he
says that Democrats value virtually
virtue signaling over problem solving we
talk about this culturally but as a
matter of policy this is a quote and too
many local Democrats insist on virtue
signaling proposing half-baked
government programs that aim to solve
every single societal ill and on finding
new ways to thumb their noses at
Republicans at the state or federal
level so we know that this is true of
course as we just saw with the Redskins
sorry commanders
um scalpers but is it true go ahead and
wizards on a policy level here's the
truth uh yes he's correct yet again we
have a brand oh like black Jesus boy New
York has a brand
CBDs it means something
[Music]
Kansas doesn't have a brand
yeah the people well you know what
but New York has a brand
[Music]
that was weirder and I knew it ran with
that one I love it let's just beef with
Kansas man I know I don't know they're
white they just they're just doing their
own business getting tornadoes and
midgets and stuff
tornadoes it's you know what New York is
New York City it's the biggest city in
the world filled with rednecks people
don't know they're just big City
Rednecks they don't know what it's like
to have a car to drive somewhere else to
enjoy freedoms I used to live in New
York and I hated it I always hated it
yeah and they said well you know the
thing about New York is it's so
convenient I go what
yeah to who when I would have to go down
to Fox News and I was I was living uh on
seven somewhere around like 77 what they
called Yorkville right 77th and uh and
past Second Avenue so that's okay I have
one subway line and it's usually full so
it goes right past me if I were to drive
in my car it would be a six minute drive
anywhere else in the country but it
takes me at least 35 minutes if I don't
just have to say screw it get out of the
subway station and walk anyway because
there's no cab available they think it's
convenient because things are close I've
never had so much so close and
completely out of reach a lot of people
in New York don't know what a price
looks like outside of their City they
don't know what Transportation looks
like outside of their City they don't
know what what infrastructure looks like
outside of their City they have no idea
it's more like a third world uh Market
with barkers people don't realize that
in New York they take this we have a
brand yeah well guess what your brand
sucks your new Coke of cities
yeah that was bad too you are the Zima
of municipalities I just asked a real
quick question here I know we have to
move on we're going a little bit long
here but just go back up to his quote
that he said the reason right right
above there where we have it so he says
right here
all of these things Democrats and such
virtue signaling half-baked government
programs why were you one then
did you just figure this out yeah like
you have like you're saying all of the
right things right now but this is so
obvious that it's not like you had an
aha moment there was no Flash of Genius
here this was just you kind of playing
politics I will say and you get this a
lot with Texas even the Republicans
where they're not super conservative
either they're kind of entrenched where
the Republicans can be pretty damn
moderate yeah and the Democrats can be
pretty damn moderate and so they end up
just kind of clustering toward the
middle and that's what gives me pause it
does I want to give them the benefit of
the doubt because I know people do
switch people people they feel a certain
way they believe a certain way and then
they that that line right there the
half-baked idea line that makes me think
it's real because he was tired of
sitting there having ideas never having
to come through other people have an
idea supporting them never going through
never working yeah I I think I I hope so
I know I hope so it needs to be what's
your genius moment which is when did you
officially realize okay this can no
longer work right so
um Mayor Johnson also said that the
overwhelming majority of Americans who
call our cities home deserve to have
real choices not quote unquote
Progressive Echo Chambers at City Hall
um but the real reason we think that he
changed parties or at least a primary
reason is he got sick of the liberal
City homeless washing his windshield
with bum piss
[Music]
and by the way it's good Arc you guys
may not remember this during covet I did
a walk and talk with Alex Jones yeah
um it's not a joke it is an actual
epidemic the bum piss epidemic here's a
clip from back then if you missed it
Compass is bad enough I think I think
about this is worse than dust mites
oh my God I'm serious I smell that I
can't do it
[Laughter]
that's bad
they're mice I was like there's mice
they're mites I'm sorry my mouth will
just really tried the bump is
it's so bad I can't lift can we film can
we film can we film not let's get in the
car Let's uh let's get away from the
river
a tank drives up he's like good in the
car we're still down there away from the
mites and the bum piss I'm like we need
to evade the mites in the Bumpass by
going in your tank
yes all right okay that's fine then I
guess I will I love how like Alex Jones
like almost throws up in Alex Jones
voice
[Laughter]
he does yeah well it's it's just it was
aggressive not always Gerald throws up
in a different it sounds like a like a
nesting bird like no that's weird I
throw up like Alex Jones
I go all in
you know what I hate in
someone throws up you know if it's a
woman they don't want to be so gross
they just make it sound like a cough
like and this goes up like that yeah no
for me it's like a tube of toothpaste
it's a five minute heave session yeah
and then afterwards you're like ah do
you notice that though in films so I was
like like a cough who throws up like
that you don't need to be cute when you
throw up this is why both women aren't
funny now I did see you once they're
open to a shot glass once really yeah I
went and then put it back and then went
back to dancing
that must been that's not a lot of throw
up that's my friend Stephen weiburn yep
he did that wow good for him yeah he's a
cop in Miami
so this is just so you know this is
historic because this is the um the
largest GOP LED City now in the country
there aren't many I believe before this
Oklahoma city was the only city with
like a Republican mayor yeah but a
significant a large big urban area this
is a large city Tennessee yeah we'll see
what happens what do you think there Joe
so look like a lot of like a lot of the
job growth in in Dallas area has been
caused by like suburbs places where
people have a little bit more land it's
a lot more conservative the minute you
get out of the Cities that's a common
story around the country but probably
more so in Texas with all of the
different cities in the city very
democrat-controlled outside Republicans
so I understand that there's pressure I
understand that there are people saying
this guy wants to do a Statewide race
maybe run for governor soon you're not
going to get that on the Democrat ticket
so go to the Republican side of The
Ledger and see if you can make some
Headway there I just hope he brings
conservative policies to that office I
don't want him just to be the same guy
with a different label and I fear that
that's maybe what we'll have right now
so that he can kind of Advance his
political career so I I know this sucks
but you have to to take kind of a wait
and see approach like okay what's your
next policy that's going to be different
than it may be maybe we can have them on
the show let's see if people get in the
control room if we can get uh I keep
wanting to say atoms what's it what is
this it's Johnson Johnson Adams Adams as
a guy who's talking about New York's
brand and uh you know yeah great he's a
very high-ranking member of the turtles
Club as well
let's have them on the show and let's
see you know what I'm always willing to
hear someone else I am cautiously I'm
skeptically optimistic because if you
look at the state of our cities across
this uh this country they've never
really gotten it right no but at least
the Ukraine is doing well
[Music]
I gotta say better friend it's a pretty
good Smash Mouth yeah it's a
surprisingly good Smash Mouth I think
that by the way I think ukrainians are
making so much money they're getting
American mail order wives now are they
oh yeah it's the other way around you
know you've made it when you can buy
wives from other countries there are
ukrainians Tick Tock has a all sales or
final return policy so be very very
careful
and you have to create ship that
now
by the way the debate sir so there will
be no show in the morning we are doing
the live fact check I believe Nick de
Paulo is here so that's 8 30 Eastern
with the drinking game rules to follow I
don't know if we have those yet if
they've gone out drinking game rules
we'll have some guests we'll be live
fact-checking it we'll give you our our
pregame and our post game and of course
it's about two times longer if you are a
member over there um at mug Club yeah
it's gonna be a fun night and Josh where
are you performing uh Summit City comedy
club in Fort Wayne on the 19th of
October all right so we're going to
continue here today there's a segment
that we've wanted to get to for a while
it's not the most topical but I think it
matters it's about uh state flags being
racist
it's just just just go with it so if you
want to continue watching this we'll be
taking your chat if you're watching on
Rumble right now you just click that
button right there and you get to keep
watching seamlessly every day through
mug Club you don't have to switch you
don't have to go to a whole new URL just
a lot of cutter.com if you're not
watching on Rumble but really head on
over and watch on Rumble Rumble hey
thank you genuinely and make sure that
Chris I never talk to them you're the
one who talks to them yeah that's true I
shame them mostly Chris hey I'll I guess
because I don't know if I want to out
their names or if they don't want
anymore but hey public okay Chris Assaf
all you guys genuinely and folks out
there retweet let Rumble know we
appreciate you standing in the fire
alongside with us we've never been with
a company with who has these kinds of
brass balls and we understand that
they're they're International
governments right now who want to see
Rumble go away understand the fight that
you're up against and you can support
them just by watching on their platform
as opposed to YouTube or joining mug
Club are there other people at Rumble
who also have kind of like their
equivalent to patreon but you know with
Mud Club you get the entire umbrella
thank you Rumble thank you Chris thank
you Asaf
genuinely beyond the business
relationship it really does uh it
galvanizes all of us to see that you
actually care and you actually Practice
What You Preach so Rumble from the
bottom of our hearts thank you very much
we're going to talk about racist state
flags YouTube piss off and eat a bag of
just cut it eat a bag
foreign
[Applause]